marg were here at collector mania you've
had a great season again on Game of
Thrones so far this year one of the
moments it stood out for me for gren was
when you're talking about they tell you
about the Nights Watch and honor but
they don't tell you about the shoveling
[ __ ] and maybe think what surprising
thing did you find they didn't tell you
when you signed on for Game of Thrones
first of all the longevity at the at the
beginning out we weren't sure whether or
not a second season was going to be
taken on so the surprise of having the
second season than a third season and
now you know probably leading into a
fourth season no it's looking very good
but of course when you first start you
haven't read all the books so you don't
know where you stand in terms of story
what's going to happen whether or not
you're just going to may remain you know
fair not really essential to the story
but as it builds and builds and you get
through the books you know you realize
just I essentially you're gonna become
and and how important everybody is in
the Castro what is it you've enjoyed
most about playing grand
I mean returning each year to see the
same guys you know John Bradley Kit
Harington Ben Compton and Joe Alton and
course and course Luke as well it's
always great returning back to them
excite returning back to her family for
a lot of us it was our first jobs out of
drama school so you know it's nice to be
able to return back and see everybody
and we actually have interviewed girls
in a couple of times and one of our fans
said that pip and Grenn need their own
spin-off show what do you think I'd be
like I thought I'd be great yeah
probably a lot of quips from Pitt and a
lot of slow movement from Graham not
really many comebacks it might be a bit
of a one-way street certainly with Joe
anyway cuz you know he's always got a
lot to say it's Joe
but yeah I think absolutely hey you
should send it to the makers of thumb
the guy and see what they say about it
I've nobody I'm living the idea now
there's been an interesting relationship
with Sam well as well there's Caesar and
the end of last season because you and
dolorous EDD kind of left him didn't you
with the white Walker what was that all
about I think we posted out a bit I
think it puts it out but you know I
think you see in season three that we're
in regret of that and you know on the
bound as we are we realize what we did
and hence why you see was helping him so
much and I'm sure that will continue
throughout now you know I think the
unity that the writers have created
between our characters in that
close-knit environment now will will
only will only go forward and gather
more and more momentum I think so you
know we left him once but I don't think
it'll happen again
what do you think about the turnaround
for Sam from cowering before the white
Walker going to be say to white Walker
Celaya yeah no yeah I think John will
probably love that when he first saw it
realizing they was gonna be the hero in
the darkness um no yeah absolutely
he's got a massive set turnaround and
you know a good MIT good bit of meat for
him to chew on as an actor and and as a
storyline you know you know and you get
an interesting storyline like that
you're really gonna you're gonna get
your teeth into it and I think he's
really enjoying it everybody loving it
yeah now we know we see that gren wasn't
happy about maybe meeting his end by a
white Walker but if you had to die in
the show and I'm doing what you do how
would you like to meet your maker I
think it'd have to be riding into battle
with a double-edged axe in one hand and
a scream of glory in my throat riding
into into an army of wildlings or
something like that
he's gonna have to be glorious every day
I always go see it now yeah I'd love to
make it yeah but you let's just see if
we can get the producers on board got
some great ideas coming out today and
telling you yeah absolutely no they're
great them guys great eyebrows just been
a little so-and-so hasn't he just sees
he's not really a great friend of time
Wells and therefore not groans over what
do you think of his treatment of poor
Sam I know if Luke wasn't such a nice
person
it'd be quite easy just to hate him
through and through but yeah he plays
the character so well and you know you
get to see the sides of him
the inventor sees he's basically
portraying evil and that's what he's
supposed to be the corruptor and yeah we
need to keep an eye on him big time but
you know where we left off in Episode
four of this season I'm sure you know
we'll return back to it and you'll find
out exactly what's happened and we're
still yet to know what's going on
exactly so yeah hopefully though your
gates come up and certainly and no
Mormont anymore no too big to me big
Jimmy Kosmos copped it he's popped his
clogs and he's gone now yeah I know such
a loss as well you know as a group we
all well got along so well and a good
time hey he's a shame to see Jimmy go
but and of course commander moment but
someone's gotta fill his shoes
and we shall see weapons exciting stuff
hey now I read the from writer Bryan
cogman who was on a show that you might
have read some of KITT scenes with Rose
a table readings for season three
particularly the you know nothing Jon
Snow Oh moment oh yeah well I had done a
how many parts I read the wrong man he
said do you want to read a couple of
parts I said yeah is anybody else doing
it they said yeah fine couple of people
are doing it I said fine turn upon the
day I think I read about nine parts
at kraznys Jon Snow I've read a lot of
parts I think I did kit harington's yeah
but I'd have probably been too busy
looking at Rose Leslie to remember
anybody else remember anything yeah just
an urban haze why not and what you're
looking forward to with season four
coming ahead well I mean I'm a still
speculation I have no idea what's going
to happen and as far as the books that
writers they're pulling tugging things
here there and everywhere and tightening
some bits and I wasn't as into other
bits like the Theon Greyjoy story that's
come Gus come forward a lot so I don't
know I really don't know I mean I'm
looking forward to getting out there and
having a battle with the wildlings
hopefully you know touchwood will be
involved in that
yeah I'm looking forward to getting out
to Belfast and swinging swinging a sword
around we're looking forward to seeing
you doing it now what's it meant to you
to be part of Game of Thrones and Mark
and finally do you want to give a
message to the fans out there who watch
this into as well yeah absolutely I mean
Game of Thrones was the first my first
job at and it will remain my base and
somewhere to always return to and
because the show was snow balled as it
is I won't be sad here without the show
so that I'm grateful completely grateful
for it and for the fans you know you've
just got to keep watching keep waiting
keep anticipating and make sure that you
make sure that you stay tuned and as
much as you speculate I'm sure that you
won't be able to find out what's going
on until it happens
you